we have this uh from the New York
intelligence or when Marjorie Taylor
green says National divorce she means
another civil war all right well maybe I
don't think so
but there's a viral it's trending on
Twitter with now many conservatives and
Libertarians saying National divorce is
a very very bad idea because it would
just mean that China Stomps out what's
left of the U.S once we once we
disassociate a breakup some people are
calling it a delusion saying the country
is mostly blue cities with red rural
areas my attitude is I don't know about
need a national divorce I know Michael
Miles talks quite a bit about it but I
just know that the Divide between cities
and rural areas or red red areas and
blue areas is so different it is
completely different dimensions of of
perception and reality it is people in
one state
uh in California with open borders with
child sex changes with Limitless
abortion that is it has drifted so far
away from where traditional Americans
are where even moderate like liberal
types are that there's no bringing that
back together so you can argue we we
can't have a national divorce and it's
like sure how does a country exist when
two states have laws that are so
Divergent and cultural views are so
Divergent they're ready to start
shooting each other
right so I don't I don't know I don't
think Margaret Taylor green saying Civil
War no she's attempting to avoid war at
all costs from what I've said what she's
told me is that she has kids and she
does not want her kids fighting in a war
to die so this is she thinks that a
national divorce could prevent but
that's literally I think it's
short-sighted personally that's
literally what the first Civil War was
the South attempted a peaceful divorce
saying we sign it we voted on it we
agreed on it have a nice day and the
union said f no we're sending in the
troops and then tried calling in troops
and then a bunch of other states joined
check out the story from timcast.com
attacks on power grid up 71 officials
say the number of politically or
ideologically motivated tax is growing
so welcome to your daily well I don't
think it's fair to call it a black pill
here's why
black pilling to me is like Despair and
depression like it's all bad and I don't
think bad is the right word to describe
a circumstance that just happens to be
bad things are happening bad things
happen good things happen after bad
things I mean the Roman Empire collapsed
through the Dark Ages and then you know
things we had a Renaissance we had a
golden age things got better let me
granted there were plagues in war and
other things like that but it's an ebb
and flow you can't expect all of life on
the planet to always be sitting in your
lounge chair eating a bowl of nachos
watching a football game there's gonna
be hardship especially when weak men
make hard times but then Hard Men hard
times will make strong men what I see
right now is we have the unfortunate
privilege of being
uh all of you listening the strong man
in the weak time I'm sorry in the in the
bad time weak men have made a bad time
and we are now getting to to what may be
the bottom of it maybe it gets worse but
then it's gonna it's gonna require
strong men people like you watching to
do what it takes to fortify defend
expand protect the ideals that we care
about for all of the insanity in this
country when it comes to the culture war
with far left side psychotic individuals
with weird gender ideology we all know
that stuff can't survive the Soviet
Union lasted what 69 years that's it the
United States has been around for for
over 250 some 270 something
so was it two no 250 something right so
we've done a pretty good job much better
than the Soviet Union their Union
collapsed
in the event these lunatics start
destroying our institutions and they are
in the in the event the institutions
crumble their ideas will cease to exist
because they only exist within the
confines of this protective bubble and
then strong individuals will just pick
things back up get back to work and
preserve the ideals of uh individual
liberty Freedom Etc except what happened
with Atlantis there are there are
situations where we could completely
annihilate everything and start from the
ground start from Rock Bottom literally
the Stone Age where we need to figure
out how to how to carve metal with rock
yeah but if that occurred that wasn't
self-inflicted that we know of but it
might have been they might have had some
sort of vibrational technology that
lowered the Earth's magnetic field and
allowed meteors to land on the planet
who knows like it's the it could be it's
the implosion Annihilation as opposed to
the explosion Annihilation which would
be nuclear war you know that's one
possible maybe it was maybe it was just
coincidence maybe but they they could
have used technology that annihilated
them there's no way to know but
regardless I mean now we need to channel
resources
effectively towards the causes that we
believe in and you know some people call
it uh parallel economy there's this
whole concept of a network state that
Balaji has come up with through a really
interesting book sort of about how you
know social networks online communities
are going to crowdsource particularly
with crypto because you know that is a
fully independent outside economic
structure and so we're already building
up the parallel world and it's going to
happen simultaneously like this idea
that there's going to be some sort of
like
you know uh perfect like collapse and
then it's just not all going to happen
at once it's gonna happen slowly over
time and we're seeing the Alternatives
build up so there's all kinds of
sustainable conscious communities all
over the world that are that are tuning
in to how to do things the right way so
I I think that you know what you're
saying to him like Solutions are
happening it's it's slowly getting built
up I'm really excited to do a cast
Castle Yellowstone parody
about the cast The Castle Ranch and
where chicken ranchers and they keep
trying to steal our land you know we're
we'll go out and we'll herd the chickens
it'll be really funny I think it's nice
to live through prosperous times but I
think as an individual you have more
influence during difficult times right
the way you choose to live your life
during challenges and the values that
you choose to fight for and the changes
you choose to make for your life you
know right now if this is a difficult
time they are more likely to determine
the course of your your personal history
as well as your family's history as well
as your community's history I mean this
is the time that you have the chance to
make the biggest difference just by the
way you choose to live and demonstrate
your values I like the I like to a
certain degree the hard times
I don't like the idea that people have
to suffer like the idea of saying like
oh hard times are great it's like that
means people are doing really bad it's
like when Bill Maher said if you know if
a recession will stop Trump then bring
on the recession and that's like a
horrible thing but me personally uh I I
I I prefer the active not the inactive
and so maybe Hard Times isn't the right
word I like seeing people be logical and
active in building their communities up
protecting them figuring out how to make
things work that means going to meetings
it means it means struggle it means it
means to a certain degree conflict like
political conflict not violence I'm
talking about going to a meeting and a
guy like no your policy on this is wrong
I prefer a society of people who are
constantly fighting for what is best
because it's the sedentary it's the lazy
it's the inactive which results in real
hard times when the food goes missing
when the crime runs rampant that's what
we're seeing right now this is
multiculturalism ladies and gentlemen
this is what happens when the Utopia of
multiculturalism comes to your country
this idea that they try to make it seem
like multiculturalism multiculturalism
is when people of different backgrounds
all live together in harmony what it
really means is the values you have
aren't shared by your neighbors which
means they don't know and they don't
care about you so when you say something
like I believe in free speech they go no
then your government decides the lowest
common denominator is the way things are
to be run and that means no free speech
because then someone's gonna get mad
somewhere no we can't live that way you
got to maintain an overarching culture a
parent culture of the content we like
the things we agree on the things we
disagree on the things that are illegal
the things that are legal and then
underneath that say a U.S Constitution
that guarantees Free Speech oh you can
believe whatever you want to believe you
can live in an area called Ukrainian
Village in Chicago or Chinatown where
you are mostly surrounded by people who
come from the same place as you you can
speak about the ideas you want your
culture can exist underneath the U.S
cultural umbrella but this idea of
multiculturalism as they describe it is
basically U.S culture next to say like
uh Middle Eastern cultures which they
Clash free speech and blasphemy laws
they don't they don't they don't go
together it's like a Melting Pot with
the temperature turned down there's no
melting anybody anybody knows who's
making a cheese sauce certain cheeses
are hard cheeses they don't melt so well
right so I I made it I did provolone
cheddar with cajun spice and Parmesan
but the parmesan doesn't want to melt
and so that's you got a Melting Pot it
can work cheese sauce was delicious but
the parmesan stayed solid floating we
need to turn up the temperature
culturally without sparking the nuclear
temperature uh explosions I'm talking
about making people laugh and find joy
and and it actually engage with their
pain and acknowledge it and like let it
happen I think people would have to want
to participate then right like if you
have a culture that you love and you
identify with and it's in Conflict to us
values why would you want to adopt U.S
values if you're happy with the values
of your society and your culture and
everything about it I mean you have to
there is some active participation like
the idea of a Melting Pot is nice and
it's it's a good uh metaphor in a lot of
respects but it negates the fact that
people have to actively choose to uh
want to become part of the American
cultural Fabric and I think that that's
not true for everyone I think being in a
new Geographic space isn't the same
thing as wanting to be a part of a new
experience right that's why we talk
about early immigration to America I
think like Ellis Island and everything
like there are people who had their
cultures but they also wanted to be here
because there was a dream and there was
a vision and I don't know that our
culture as a society has that same sort
of desire to blend well there's people
all over Earth that would be make better
Americans than a lot of people that are
in the country right now that are actual
citizens because that's their their
beliefs are I talk to them online I have
video chats with people in other
countries that are smarter and more
Adept than you know the beer drinking
football lovers no offense if you that's
you but if you got a beer gut you're a
problem fix it well in terms of who is
co-opting the culture I mean if we if
you look at open Ai and chat GPT and
like how in all the search engines you
know basically they are engineering
culture they're trying to and so
what's happening I actually got chat GPT
to admit that it is using data that it
doesn't have the rights to
and that's a good one yeah wow and so
they admitted that they should not be
using it commercially yeah and because
what what are they doing they're they're
grabbing all data from everywhere that
they can on permission without
permission and in your data your data
your data is all in there feeding it
making it more valuable to them so I
think we need to sue open AI on some
sort of class action lawsuit so that
they share Revenue with the people whose
data they're actually using and you know
we obviously need something that is
uncensored
um on the side and unbiased even though
that is going to be a chaotic animal
that is gonna be just as offensive but
it does need to exist thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time